lorsque l'on parcourt les stands du
salon des arts ménagers
la première chose qui frappe c'est le
nombre d'objets qui sont fabriqués en
matière plastique
depuis quelques temps on assiste à une
véritable invasion
à telle enseigne que nos grands mères
lorsqu'elle se promène dans une boutique
10 mais qu'est ce qu'on ne fait pas en
matière plastique
oui qu'est-ce qu'on ne fait pas en
plastique le plastique est partout avec
du plastique ont fait tous le faire
disparaît peu à peu car on avait des
ennuis avec la corrosion
le plastique le supplante
[Musique]
ceci ce n'est pas du plastique
c'est du bois matériau traditionnel par
excellence que l'on a utilisé pendant de
très nombreuses générations seulement
n'oublions pas qu'on a utilisé le bois
parce qu'on n'avait pas autre chose sous
la main l'avènement du fer a marqué un
progrès pour l'humanité
on avait un matériau beaucoup plus
rigide et peu à peu il a supplanté le
bois on peut dire que notre civilisation
technique est bâti sur le faire
seulement il existe un autre matériau
qui lui aussi a supplanté un peu le
faire dans certains domaines ce fut le
vert le vert est aussi un matériau
traditionnel seulement ils présentent un
énorme inconvénient sa mise en oeuvre
ces procédés d'élaboration son long
fastidieux fer vert bois voilà une
trilogie sur laquelle a été bâti toute
notre civilisation
seulement la technologie permet
maintenant de fabriquer de nouveaux
matériaux
si l'on mettait le temps du plastique en
musique vas-y vas-y qu'on y perdrait son
temps de temps en temps en y gagnant des
ce et des bijoux des bijoux en plastique
ya plus économique
camille que mhidia plus intéressant
faurecia manqueront pas que l'on pend au
regard de foi la vie c'est bien plus
fantastique est il que tu qu'on y voit
le printemps rassemblera faire des
gaffes et redécouvert en papier
[Musique]
oui en effet qu'est ce que le plastique
monsieur léger vous qui êtes ingénieur
chimiste dans cette usine de matières
plastiques pour vous qu'est ce que c'est
que le plastique je vois qu'il est
nécessaire de définir cette herbe
classique pour bien pour la ménagère
on appelle le plastique en somme tout ce
qui n'est pas fait avec des matériaux
traditionnels comme le fer le bois ou le
vert oui mais veilleux ce thème
classique est un terme péjoratif due à
une période merveilleuse
pénurie des matières premières ou ces
matières de ces matériaux traditionnels
ont été remplacés par les plastiques
mais depuis ces matières plastiques ont
prévenus et ont obtenu ont atteint les
performances techniques et
technologiques terre qu'à l'heure
actuelle elles sont utilisées ld seront
de plus en plus utilisé dans toutes les
industries
à tel point que l'on peut admettre à
l'heure actuelle que d'ici la fin
d'année le volume de production les
matières plastiques de l'industrie des
matières plastiques sera égale sinon
supérieure à 7 à la sidérurgie
bon alors le plastique c'est avant tout
un matériau le plastique est un matériau
un matériau artificiels créés et
fabriqués par l'homme oui le plastique
est un matériau artificiel c'est du
synthétique comme l'on dit mais pour le
fabriquer il faut bien partir de quelque
chose donc les matières plastiques sont
des substances artificielles
mais pour les fabriquer par qui vient de
quelque chose le partant de produits de
base
liquides ou gazeux qui sont des dérivés
du charbon ou du pétrole est de plus en
plus
quand l'or ici dans cette usine de
fabrication de matières plastiques
quel est votre point de départ vient
nous utilisons un produit de bar le
styrène produits liquides durée dolo
seulement et de ce produit liquide
nous obtenons en définitive ce produit
et c'est ça la matière plastique c'est
ceci la matière plastique et où se fait
le passage donc de ce liquide à la
matière plastique qui est solide nous
introduisons dans cet appareil le
produit liquide dans le haut de cette
première et par une succession de
transformation chimique nous obtenons le
produit solide la police
comment se fait cette transformation et
bien simplement parce que les chimistes
appelle une polymérisation
cela consiste tout simplement à
accrocher des molécules les unes aux
autres
un peu à la manière des wagons pour
faire un train on obtient alors une
poudre une poudre blanche pour des
raisons esthétiques on va la colorée on
va donc la mélanger à des colorants la
réchauffer pour obtenir ce boudin qui
sort de la machine
le boudin passe dans une filière pour
obtenir de long macaronis coloré qui
vont être haché menu menu pour faire des
granulés ça sera ça la matière plastique
tels que l'on pourra l'utiliser
[Musique]
non
voilà la matière première empaqueté dans
des containers là se termine le travail
du fabricant en quelque sorte maintenant
après expédition on le retrouve chez un
utilisateur c'est à dire un
transformateur la matière se présente
donc sous ces granulés qui vont être
aspiré un peu à la manière des grains de
blé dans un silo avant de subir la phase
de transformation
[Musique]
les grains de matières plastiques sont
réchauffés dans la machine que nous
voyons on leur donne une consistance
d'une pâte molle qu'un piston pousse
dans un moule de façon à obtenir
directement la pièce fabriquée
comme vous le voyez le procédé est
simple rapide et efficace en moins de 30
secondes à partir de granulés de
matières premières on obtient un objet
fini prête à l'emploi ici serait
intéressant d'établir un parallèle avec
les matériaux traditionnels comme
l'acier en effet à partir du minerai de
fer
on obtient par à l'aide du haut fourneau
l'acier cet acier doit être cool et puis
la pièce après des moulages doit être
ébarber subir après d usinage alors
qu'ici rien de tout cela on obtient un
produit fini un produit prêtes à
l'emploi
[Musique]
voilà mes nageurs comment naissent vos
ustensiles ménagers que ça soit à un
casque séchoir ou bien un robot pour
faire la cuisine
ce ne sont que des pièces de plastique
assemblée mais c'est du véritable
plastique c'est un matériau noble qui
doit tenir sa place dans votre panoplie
ah ah
[Musique]